que la selva ecuatoriana sea reconocida
como un ser vivo consciente y sujeto de
derechos esa es la petición que hacen
los quechuas de sarayaku a la corte
constitucional ecuatoriana esto en una
audiencia que solicitaron para ver el lo
que ellos llaman incumplimiento de la
sentencia de la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos que falló a su favor
hace una década y es que la corte les
dio la razón pidiendo que el estado
ecuatoriano consultará previamente con
las comunidades indígenas y también
pidiendo que retiraran los explosivos
que las petroleras sembraron en su
territorio para buscar hidrocarburos
pero además como medida de reparación
ante el incumplimiento prolongado los
indígenas están pidiendo que la amazonía
se declare como un ser vivo algo similar
ocurrió en colombia en 2018 cuando la
corte suprema de justicia dijo que la
selva amazónica era sujeto de derechos
sin embargo la diferencia es que no
hablaba de un ser viviente esto haría
que si la corte constitucional
ecuatoriana les da la razón a los
indígenas sería un fallo pionero en
materia ambiental hablamos con josé
gualinga líder de los sarayaku y nos
explicó qué significa este concepto
en su todo en su conjunto
está
compuesto de seres protectores quienes
secundan fertilizan regulan la tierra y
eso es a
esa regulación
esa fecundación que está ligado al
pueblo sarayacu a los pueblos
originarios es lo que nos da la vida